[Music]
Chris Pratt has gone country y'all on
Thursday the 40 year old actor surprised
fans when he stopped by two iconic
country music venues in Nashville and
jumped on stage to sing with the band
[Music]
that's Chris wowing the crowd with his
rendition of Johnny Cash's Folsom Prison
Blues at Roberts Western vault Chris
kept Akash wearing a denim shirt and a
white baseball cap and posted up with
Sarah Gayle Meech a Nashville based
country singer who was performing at the
venue when he showed up she shared the
snap on Instagram with the caption quote
thank you at Pratt Pratt Pratt you made
our night it was Chris also took the
stage at Nashville's iconic tootsies
world-famous orchard lounge where this
happened but Chris's musical chops
should come as no surprise he's saying
on parks and recreation
[Music]
[Applause]
on Saturday Night Live in 2014
home where the heart is and minds right
here and he did a duet with Chris
Stapleton on Jimmy Kimmel Live in 2017
but who could forget when he rapped
Eminem's forgot about Dre word-for-word
in 2014 nowadays everybody want to talk
they got something to say but nothing
comes out when they move the lips just a
bunch of gibberish but exactly they
forgot about Dre he's even saying for
the et cameras in 2016
[Music]
[Applause]